Also was nun?
Gibt es jetzt Planet 9 oder nicht?
Eine aktuelle Studie legt die Vermutung nahe,
dass ein Ring aus Abertausenden kleineren
Objekten einen ähnlichen Effekt haben könnte
wie ein einzelner Planet.
Und eine weitere Studie bestätigt wiederum
Planet 9 und zwar als Supererde!
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Nur hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann und nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen.
Rein in die Kartoffeln, raus aus den Kartoffeln.
Also was stimmt nun?
Ist die Theorie von Planet 9 nun entkräftet
oder im Gegenteil sogar bekräftigt?
Der Reihe nach.
Ende Januar erschien eine Studie mit, ja einer
ernüchternden These: Könnte es sein, dass
Planet 9 gar nicht existiert?
Ist der Planet ein reines Hirngespinst beziehungsweise
ist der Wunsch Vater des Gedanken und damit
der Grund gefunden, warum wir Planet 9 immer
noch nicht entdeckt haben?
Die These: Ein Ring aus Abertausenden Objekten,
die zusammen die bis zu zehnfache Erdmasse
hätten, hätte zusammen den gleichen Effekt
auf die Umlaufbahnen zahlreicher transneptunischer
Objekte kurz TNOs, also Asteroiden und Zwergpalneten,
wie ein einzelner Planet.
Bäm.
Das sagt die Studie von Jihad Touma von der
American University of Beirut und Antranik
Sefilian von der University of Cambridge aus.
Planet 9 also Pustekuchen?
Jihad Touma „Die Hypothese von Planet Neun
ist faszinierend.
Wir wollten jedoch nachprüfen, ob es eine
andere, weniger dramatische und vielleicht
natürlichere Ursache für die merkwürdigen
Bahnen geben könnte, die wir bei einigen
TNOs sehen."
Ihr Studie berücksichtigt ihren Angaben zufolge
zum ersten Mal auch den Rest des Sonnenesystems.
Sie sagen: "In Kombination mit einem vereinfachten
Modell des Sonnensystems könnte das die ungewöhnliche
Orbitalarchitektur einiger Brocken am äußeren
Ende des Sonnensystems erklären" Die beiden
Wissenschaftler gingen in ihrer ersten Studie
von einem gigantischen Ring von Objekten aus
und tatsächlich er beeinflußte der Umlaufbahnen
der transneptunischen Objekten genauso wie
ein hypothetischer Planet 9.
Also hat sich die Wissenschaft geeirrt.
Dazu muss man sagen: Nur eins ist sicher:
Objekte jenseits des Neptuns haben exzentrische
Umlaufbahnen.
Irgendetwas stört sie so, dass es jeweils
„Beulen“ in ihrem Orbeit gibt.
Das ist zigfach bestätigt und unzweifelhaft.
Doch was verursacht diese „Beulen“?
Dazu gibt es nur unbestätigte Hypothesen.
Und dazu ist jetzt aktuelle eine weitere gekommen.
Denn die zwei der wichtigen Verfechter der
Planet 9-Theorie haben „zurückgeschlagen“.
Michael Brown und Konstantin Batygin vom California
Institute of Technology (Caltech) haben nun
tausende Computermodelle durchgerechnet und
damit erneut überprüft, ob Planet 9 existieren
könnte oder nicht.
Und die Ergebnisse sind spektakulär!
Erstmal haben sie die Chancen für Planet
9 auf 500:1 gerechnet und sie haben eine neue
Bahn und eine andere Größe für Planet 9
errechnet.
Demnach ist er nicht bis zu 1000 astronomische
Einheiten (das ist der Abstand Erde, Sonne).
Sondern nur 400 von der Sonne entfernt und
er ist nicht bis zu 10 Mal so groß wie die
Erde, sondern nur bis zu fünf Mal.
"Bei fünf Erdmassen ähnelt Planet 9 wahrscheinlich
eher einer typischen extrasolaren Super-Erde",
sagt Batygin.
Damit würde auch die Möglichkeit eines Gasplaneten
entfallen.
Und es könnte sehr spannend werden, wie diese
Supererde dann aussieht.
Leben auf Exoplaneten - Neue Erkenntnisse
zur Entstehung von Leben.
Hier draufklicken für dieses Video.
Sehr sehr spannend, also anklicken, angucken,
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!